what do you think that other filmmakers
what would you recommend to them
that they can do to set themselves up so
that they can prove to the right people
that they can have confidence not in
just their work
but also them showing up staying with
the project doing what they say they're
going to do on time
because isn't that so much of what it is
they're like they're looking for people
not just who are
incredibly talented but also that are
going to be reliable or maybe i'm wrong
is that
yeah no i think i think you learn as you
go like what kind of people are reliable
and you can sense that pretty quick if
you've got somebody who will
will help you and work with you and
collaborate
and in a lot of cases like i can't pay
people what i probably should be able to
pay people but i do everything
i can to give them back in on my films
and i talk with them and i say like
listen this is my approach i'm very
transparent
i'm doing everything i can to raise the
money up front not to have a lot of debt
or
investment oftentimes on these films so
that when we get to market on a film
everybody's going to start to see some
cash and it may not come across as
quickly as they want you never know how
well a film will do but i think that's
been a pretty cool approach to get
people
invested in me you know invested in or
the pro the film the product that we're
eventually going to deliver
so there they go so
um but yeah i mean i think it's
it's uh it's it's it's definitely tough
sometimes though because i think people
have such a jaded
perspective of what film
filmmaking is once they've been inside
for a while it's not easy
you know there's oftentimes not much
money
and and so you've got to find ways to to
really get people to believe in you and
and i found that by making multiple
films and just
sticking with this course of action and
not trying to be too elaborate not
trying to aim too high
and you know keeping budgets low enough
and everything that uh people
people respect that and they see that
you know it can actually
eventually turn a profit which let's say
most my films are doing now you know
when you when you factor in sweat it's
hard to say
exactly how profitable they are but
ultimately i mean the films
are paying back all the all the costs
and getting that point where you can
distribute
you know um people share to them and and
it's tends to keep the the people that
i've worked with that i really respect
you know coming back and helping me
again
you know and there's a few key players
for sure that you'll need when you make
films like
making sure you find somebody who can do
great music you know it's always such a
huge part of story whether you're
creating it from
making an original music or sourcing you
know music that's already made out there
that's been really important and i'm you
know fortunate enough recently to have
found a guy that i really like who i can
just go back to and be like hey i need
this
and he trusts me and knows that like i
can't necessarily pay him sometimes like
when i'm in that moment of like i gotta
get this film done and packaged now
but eventually that that paycheck will
come
you